if you compare the wallet party at the
beginning to the sort of slightly later
party that devolves into the snake fight
you could sense things are starting to
kind of discombobulate
that was my only two scenes with Margot
in the history of our three films
together
[Applause]
the rattlesnake scene that was the thing
I think I was most scared of when I read
this script
how many people in their lives get to
come to work to supposedly fight a
rattlesnake it's insane
we had three real rattlesnakes big
rattlesnakes there was obviously
Prosthetics and a real combination of
things to make the rattlesnake sequence
work but it was fun it was so fun you
compare that to the Hearst party that
was another one where I've read it and I
was like oh my God how am I gonna do
this soon anytime I felt a little bit
scared of what I had to do I had to
double down and double down again and
just go way bigger way harder way
crazier otherwise it's just too scary to
do it